the best air guitarists from 16
countries are competing in oulu finland
for the title of world champion each of
them has 60 seconds to impress the jury
a weird hobby but very entertaining
it's
shortly before the finale the excited
participants receive instructions on the
stage and have a chance to rehearse
sabrina schram is here representing
germany
this will be the 23 year old's first
international performance
she's brought along her parents and
friends from bavaria to support her
just now i was standing on the stage and
saw how big it is and how many people
the room will hold
i feel really queasy
i don't know what to do
but i'm also looking forward to it a bit
when the song starts i'll forget my
nervousness i hope so anyway
elias lady liberty is a rarity in the
scene most air guitarists are male only
two women have become world champion in
the last 18 years
one of them is alina westphal from
germany known as the devil's niece she
won the title in 2011. this year she'll
perform in olu out of competition
the inhibition threshold is very high in
playing air guitar and i think men have
fewer problems overcoming their
inhibitions
women always want to look good and be
pretty and you simply can't when you
play air guitar
you make weird faces
your hair goes every which way you
scream you stand in ludicrous positions
lots of women say i wouldn't dare do
that but that's exactly what's great
about it it's so liberating
it really clears your head
anyone hoping to be crowned world
champion must exude charisma while
imitating real guitar picking finnish
rock guitarist juha torvin has been on
the jury since 1996.
even though there are five different
jurors we're usually all in agreement
about who should win
it's hard to say what makes for a winner
it's not your standard competition with
exacting criteria
it's just something you feel in your
heart
in the first round the candidates
perform songs they've prepared in
advance
the jury awards them anywhere from four
to six points
the best ten make it into the second
round in which they all have to
improvise to the same song
two americans were seen as the favorites
going in mean moline from kansas city is
the defending champ and new yorker
aristotle thrills audiences with his
comedic talent
sabine schram gave it her all on stage
and wound up in ninth place
cool there's nothing else to say it was
great fun
biggest surprise of the night was 19
year old nanami seven seas nagara from
japan
she won over the jury with her wild and
technically accomplished performance
the new world champion received an
electric guitar and amp as her prize
like each year the world championship
ended with neil young's song rocking in
the free world then all the participants
jammed together for world peace